this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by Teemu
cultures around the world have myths
that speak of a mysterious underground
Kingdom that exists deep within the
Earth hidden away from the Primitive and
violent surface dwellers which is us
picture a society Untouched by time
unscathed by War and unaffected by
natural disasters a culture thriving in
the vast Open Spaces inside the earth
throughout history many have looked for
physical evidence of its existence
tempted by stories of a peaceful but
powerful Subterranean civilization with
advanced technology and ancient
knowledge long forgotten by Modern Man
this is the story of the underground
Kingdom of agartha and the Explorers
who've said that not only is it a real
place but they know where it is
[Music]
will you hurry up I got a 6 30 res I
don't want to do this
I feel stupid but will you stop being
such a baby and get in here
remind me again why are we doing this we
are practicing for a Bigfoot Hunting
Expedition oh so that's why we've got a
campfire we've got the night vision
goggles I'm wearing this crazy suit
but what's with you in the Hat Oh My
Sweet Summer human I am a fish in the
woods we are in my world you however
need this camouflage she don't spook the
Sam's quench okay but why are we
bringing these pictures oh Gertie and I
went to them all last weekend to have
one of those uh photo booths there how
in the world did you two Think Dirty
doesn't like camping but that she
doesn't want me to forget her you know
you're codependent right of course I
know take it easy anyway where did you
get all this stuff wait
is this today's sponsor Bingo Teemu is a
global e-commerce Marketplace that sells
a huge variety of products at affordable
prices
nice job on the copy yeah thanks I've
been working with a media trainer and if
you click on the Lightning Deals Link in
the description you can find surprise
deals
who's little I files like these infrared
night vision binoculars normally 95 just
33 or a 40 ounce stainless steel tumbler
with lid not thirty dollars just eleven
dollars hey a ticket to Tumblr and show
to people would you it's in the secret
compartment of your disc yeah I don't
see it there is a scrub brush though oh
yeah I need to scrub dirty's hump later
and there's this USB speaker well that's
to play hump scrubbing music
what's Hump scrubbing music mostly light
hits and smooth jazz it really depends
on the speed
I don't and I'm sorry I asked
oh wait do you mean this tumbler that's
the one so they can get all this stuff
on Teemu Tumblr the brazy suit night
vision campfires and the speaker and the
Hop scrubber I think it's just called a
Magic Brush oh magic Is Right would I
use that thing Gertie purrs like a
kitten
so download the Tebow app from the app
store or Google Play and use the link in
the description or download and enter
code
twf050 to get 50 off your first order of
fifty dollars or more sounds pretty easy
it is okay okay time to shoot up let's
go bag of Sam squish I really don't want
to I mean
fine
you look perfect
okay okay now let's practice that
Bigfoot and mating cool I told you I'm
not
you two
hey did you just take a picture no you
did I heard you
I can't believe I got you to wear that
thing I hate you
foreign
stories of a hollow Earth have existed
in cultures for thousands of years
nearly every ancient Society has stories
about an underground realm often
inhabited by Superior beings Buddhists
firmly believe in the Subterranean
Kingdom of agartha ruled by the
mysterious king of the world oh Leonardo
DiCaprio no ah agarth is said to be home
to millions and connected to the surface
by a vast tunnel Network within the
planet's crust Indian religions speak of
a place called patala which translates
to that which is below the feet patala
is described as a beautiful land full of
Rolling Green Hills and Crystal Clear
Lakes agartha is described the same way
some believe this is the real Garden of
Eden that when God casts Adam and Eve
out of the garden he actually sent them
to the surface in an ancient Mayan text
called the purple Vu there is the story
of shabalba an underworld civilization
and from shababa twin brothers emerge
and like Adam and Eve they became the
first people above ground shikomas talk
is the place where the Aztecs emerged to
live on the surface of the Earth it
translates to seven caves and
researchers are actually looking for it
and some think they found it African and
other Native American legends also
mentioned Subterranean Realms and Cavern
Spirits the most consistent story is
that of an advanced inner earth
civilization isolated from surface
Humanity the Sumerians knew it as Kerr
avoid space or home of the Dead the
Babylonians called it urkala another
world ruled by gods the Chinese call
this underworld du and the Japanese call
it yomi ancient Egypt Islam Greek Rome
even Celtic Irish they all had myths of
an underground World more modern myths
may call this place hell but it could be
argued that hell is a relatively New
Concept that it's a construct designed
to create fear and Inspire good behavior
but before the concept of Hell the
underworld was inhabited by Advanced
god-like people who came to the surface
of the Earth once on the surface they
either created Humanity or taught
civilization to primitive humans it's
easy enough to interpret those as the
same thing and like the flood myth which
is present in every ancient culture the
inner earth story also appears over and
over again recent discoveries are
starting to point to the fact that a
great flood did really happen so when
cultures from all over the world share
the same myth we have to start looking
at all those myths as maybe more than
just a story those myths may be
referring to actual history but to prove
the existence of agartha an underground
civilization and the hollow Earth will
need more than stories we need
scientific evidence and eyewitness
testimony fortunately we have both
[Music]
the hollow Earth theory proposes that
our planet is not a solid sphere but a
hollow one with vast unexplored spaces
within in 1692 astronomer Edmund Haley
proposed a hollow Earth consisting of a
shell about 500 Miles thick within that
shell are two concentric spheres and a
central core about the diameter of Venus
Haley said the spaces in between the
shells could support life with light
provided by a luminous atmosphere in the
late 18th century mathematician Leonard
Euler used physics calculations to
hypothesize a hollow Earth with a
central Sun Euler's calculation
suggested that gravity would Propel
matter equally in all directions forming
spheres with Hollow Interiors
Hollow and flat at the same time well
the Earth isn't flat planes always fly
in a straight line if the Earth was
round they would have to adjust for that
yeah that's not how that works
if the Earth was a spinning bull you'd
be able to fly a helicopter straight up
in the air wait for the ball to spin and
then land on the other side of the
planet yeah the atmosphere spins too
yeah yeah right how fast is the Earth
spin well that depends on the latitude
between 300 and a thousand miles an hour
okay so empty air stick to the ground
moving at a thousand miles an hour yep a
perfect sink everywhere on a big round
ball yes agree to disagree
but what does modern science have to say
about the hollow Earth on the surface
the hollow Earth theory seems to defy
basic geological understanding seismic
data and the study of Earth's
gravitational field suggests that our
planet is composed of several layers the
crust the mantle and the core however
proponents of the hollow Earth theory
argue that the data are open to
interpretation they point to anomalies
in seismic readings which they claim
could be indicative of large empty
spaces within the Earth they also cite
the existence of vast underground caves
as evidence of the Earth's hollowness
and if the Earth is hollow it could
support the large population of agartha
even if the Earth isn't completely
Hollow if there are vast Hollow areas
within the Earth why couldn't they house
a hidden civilization some trace the
story of agartha back to ancient
Buddhist texts where it's described as a
paradise a place of pure Harmony and
advanced knowledge in the Western World
what we know about agartha mostly comes
from Alexander's on TV alvedre he was a
French intellectual and occultist he
spoke of agartha as a secret
civilization it's people possessing
wisdom and Technology far beyond our
understanding Santee learned of agartha
through his Sanskrit teacher who
insisted it was a real Geographic Place
santee's descriptions of agartha were
Vivid and detailed he spoke of grand
palaces illuminated by magical light and
of Advanced Technologies that harnessed
the Earth's magnetic field in the 19th
century agarthans already had Citywide
lighting Railways and even air travel
santis believed that the agarthans were
the Guardians of sacred knowledge a
knowledge that can bring about a golden
age of peace and Enlightenment on the
surface World others would continue the
search for gartha occultus Elena
blavatsky searched for evidence of a
hollow Earth and the secret tunnels that
agarthans used to travel all over the
planet but as far as we know sontive and
Madame blavatsky didn't find agartha but
not because it doesn't exist because
they didn't know where to look
but we do
foreign
the reason Edmund Haley started
exploring the idea that the Earth was
Hollow was because of strange Compass
readings in the Atlantic he believed
that the Aurora Borealis resulted from
gases escaping from the inner spheres
inside the Earth this suggested there
were entrances at the North and South
Pole and once inside you could navigate
the inner shells through vast cave and
tunnel systems the hollow Earth theory
fell out a favor for a while but gained
New Life in 1818. American John Sims
launched the notorious Sims hole theory
he declared that the Earth was Hollow
and habitable he said the inner earth is
comprised of four nested shells with
openings at the poles and Sims dedicated
much of his life to promoting this
Theory by trying to put together a polar
Expedition though that never happened
in 1829 Norwegian fisherman Olaf Janssen
claimed that he and his father sailed
through a polar opening and into the
planet's interior there they spent two
years among a race of giants before
exiting through the South Pole his story
is documented in the book The Smoky God
by Willis George Emerson which is a fun
read
but probably the most famous and
detailed account of the world inside the
earth comes from Admiral Richard E Byrd
Admiral Byrd was an aviation pioneer
polar Explorer and one of the most
decorated and celebrated officers in the
history of the American Military so a
serious guy bird took his plane out on a
quick survey mission of the North Pole
as he was flying over ice and snow he
noticed the sunlight changed then it got
warmer a few minutes later he was flying
over fields of green grass and forests
and rivers he even saw a woolly mammoth
grazing in one of those fields then he
no longer had control of his plane and
suddenly two craft came up beside him
off our port and starboard wings are a
strange type of aircraft they are
closing rapidly alongside they are disc
shaped and have a radiant quality to
them they're close enough now to see the
markings on them it is a type of
swastika this is fantastic where are we
what has happened I tug at the controls
again they will not respond we are
caught in an invisible vice grip of some
type
Admiral Byrd lands and is escorted by
tall blonde men to an underground city
there the Admiral meets someone called
the master now I link to an episode
where I go into a lot of detail about
what Admiral Byrd found so check that
out if you want to learn more I'll try
not to spoil too much here so Admiral
Byrd found a way to the hollow Earth in
the North Pole others have found their
way in through the South Pole the South
Pole is often connected to Nazi Germany
Hitler was an occultist and was famously
fascinated by the possibility that the
hollow Earth could be accessed through
Antarctica Germany did make an
expedition to Antarctica in 1938 I
theorized in the operation high jump
episode that this was the reason the
United States since it's a large
well-armed task force down there in 1946
the Germans had maps of the area
including a Cave System underneath the
surface they even had step-by-step
directions on how to get into the hollow
Earth the directions are very specific
distances right down to the meter after
follow the first eight steps the ninth
step is interesting proceed to Agatha
full speed process Straight Ahead until
the new light can be seen change of
magnetic poles the changes of the
compass needle and instruments are to be
disregarded
German U-Boat 209 commanded by einrich
Broda said he reached the interior of
the earth and found a vast network of
tunnels there are rumors that after
Germany surrendered some Nazis fled to
Antarctica and hid in these tunnels and
other rumors say they're still there but
the polls aren't the only way to get
into the cave system that leads to
agartha there are entrances all over the
world and chances are there's one near
you
thank you
[Music]
the planetary grid system is a network
of energy lines crisscrossing the planet
these lines are said to influence
everything from ancient Monument
placement to the patterns of animal
Migration the idea of a planetary grid
goes back to the ancient Greeks who
believe that a concept called emphelos
the Earth's Central Point and you can
see this concept expressed in places
like the Oracle adelphy said to be the
center of the ancient world a few
centuries later in the 1920s Alfred
Watkins noticed that ancient sites seem
to line up along straight paths he
termed these Ley lines and while some
considered his theory a coincidence
others saw a pattern connected to the
Earth's geography more recently the
unified Vector geometry theory was
proposed by Buckminster Fuller and later
developed by scientists like William
Becker and Beth Hagens
according to this Theory the Earth is
covered by an invisible grid formed by
120 identical triangles this grid
supposedly aligns with significant
geographical and historical points
across the globe take the Great Pyramid
of Giza according to the unified Vector
geometry Theory it isn't randomly placed
but occupies a crucial point on This
Global energy grid the same applies to
other ancient landmarks like Stonehenge
and Machu Picchu the Nazca Lines and
even the Bermuda Triangle
in addition to the North and South Poles
entrances to the kingdom of gartha are
also found on some of these planetary
grid points let's take a quick trip
around the world and look for a way in
the first way into the hollow Earth is
in the caves of dyros in Greece this
entrance is closely connected to Plato
and the story of Atlantis
from Greece across the Mediterranean to
mount epineo in Italy
for centuries this has been called a
portal to the inner earth
now going south across the Mediterranean
is the Pyramid of Giza
Giza doesn't seem like it would have
access to the hollow Earth but we now
know that underneath the pyramids is a
vast Cave System underground Rivers
reservoirs and tunnels with modern
technology like ground penetrating radar
new caverns and Chambers are discovered
all the time
another entrance to the Earth is said to
be within King Solomon's Minds Solomon a
king of Israel and son of King David was
known for his wisdom power and his
personal Fortune described as one of the
largest on Earth King Solomon's Minds
became known to the world because of the
famous novel featuring The Character
Alan Quartermaine an adventurer you
might remember from the movie The League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen quarterman
was played by Sean Connery
underrated movie yeah I think so too
wealth is usually associated with gold
but King Solomon's wealth is thought to
have come from the mining of copper and
these mines would have been operating
around the 13th century BC that even
though the legend of King Solomon's
Minds comes from a fictional novel
treasure Hunters believe this is a real
place and have been searching for it for
a long time
in 2008 there might have been a
breakthrough an ancient Mining City was
discovered in kerbet El najas in Jordan
their archaeologists discovered a copper
mine and a copper smelting Camp which
seemed to be operational in the 13th
century BC the team also found a lot of
personal items including clothing
Ceramics fabric even tools all
indicating a highly developed long-term
settlement at the site and these objects
have been dated to the same period as
King Solomon's Minds
the next entrance is said to be in Rama
India
for an ancient Subterranean city was
recently discovered
Tibet is home to many stories about
Hollow Earth so it's not surprising that
there are entrances underneath the
Himalayas
one of these is in the underground city
of shonshay which according to Legend
has been guarded by monks for thousands
of years
but there are entrances to the inner
earth in the West too
Iguazu in Argentina allegedly has an
entrance hidden somewhere underneath the
famous waterfalls
foreign
Brazil is said to be the city of posit
which was built by atlanteans after the
destruction of Atlantis
even the United States has gateways to
the hollow Earth
Mammoth Cave in Kentucky has been known
as an entrance since the first native
tribes arrived there thousands of years
ago
the most famous entrance to the hollow
Earth in the United States is probably
Mount Shasta
here with the city of Telos is said to
have been built and is still occupied
and there is a lot of evidence that
something is happening there I link to
an episode we did where we called Mount
Shasta the most paranormal place on
Earth and it absolutely is
and these are just a few entrances to
the kingdom of gartha in North America
there are others in Arkansas California
and other states and several locations
in Canada even the site of the secret
underground base in Dulce New Mexico was
said to be chosen because of its
proximity to an entrance to the inner
earth and we did an episode on Dulce
base as well and you might have noticed
that a lot of alleged entrances to the
hollow Earth coincide with locations
famous for UFO sightings and this might
not be a coincidence whenever someone
mentions a UFO our instinct is to look
up toward the sky to space turns out we
might be looking in the wrong direction
[Music]
foreign
we think of extraterrestrials From A
Distant star and that could be true but
there's also the theory that UFOs aren't
coming from a different planet but from
inside our planet scientifically
speaking it makes more sense that
there's a race of humanoid beings living
within the Earth as opposed to a race of
humanoid beings who have somehow figured
out how to cross the vast distances of
space and isn't it strange that the
aliens we talk about are all humanoid
whether they're the small Grays the tall
whites or even the goblin type aliens
they all kind of look like us two eyes
nose mouth two legs with feet and Toes
two arms with hands and fingers even the
size of the beings is close to the size
of humans now maybe all intelligent life
in the universe evolves this way but I
would expect life in different biomes in
different ecosystems on different
planets light years away to look
radically different than humans but they
don't so it's possible that they're from
here just in places we can't normally
see we see a lot of UFOs coming out of
the ocean but we haven't found any type
of Base at least not a confirmed
sighting so what if the base is inside
the hollow Earth under the ocean I can
think of no better Hiding Place
yeah that that would be a good hiding
place and there are crazy things
happening on The Far Side of the Moon
and an episode on that is coming up
there have been many UFO sightings
around Mount Shasta where the object
flies into the mountain and then
disappears now assuming the Witnesses
are telling the truth and I believe they
are the objects are going somewhere in
the Arctic near the North Pole the
earliest reported UFO sightings go back
to the year 1850 captain dehaven and his
medical officer saw what they thought
was a balloon but then a second object
appeared and suddenly both objects
vanished around midnight on January 22nd
1952 a strange object was tracked on
radar at a military Outpost in northern
Alaska it was moving at 1500 miles per
hour which no aircraft on Earth could do
three Jets were sent to investigate and
as the Jets approached the radar blip
slowed down and just hovered a few
seconds later it streaked out of sight
heading to the North Pole moving even
faster than before on October 5th 1960
the ballistic missile early warning
station at Thule Greenland thought World
War III had started radar was tracking
multiple objects moving at speeds too
fast to be anything except a Soviet
missile attack within minutes U.S bases
in England and Canada were mobilized and
NORAD and the Strategic Air Command were
alerted a few minutes later the radar
signals changed course and disappeared
somewhere near the North Pole the
military has been dealing with arctic
UFOs since 1945. the first UFO in Alaska
emerged from the sea in March of that
year 14 crew members on an army
transport ship witnessed the object and
approached the ship circled it and then
flew away
and there are many more sightings in the
Arctic during this time Inuits in the
Arctic regions have encountered UFOs in
the past and included them in their
myths once a man from the Buckland River
tribe discovered what appeared to be a
UFO landing site two strips of land
approximately two feet wide had been
burned all the way down to the ground on
Sledge Island Inuits have a legend of a
massive ball of fire resembling the Moon
that descended from the sky shortly
after the object was spotted a creature
described as a human skeleton appeared
in the village according to the legend
this visitor was not friendly and killed
most of the people it encountered these
are just a small fraction of the stories
about UFOs and visitors coming from the
ocean from the poles or the middle of
the Earth so we've covered the
eyewitness accounts the next piece of
the hollow Earth puzzle is scientific
evidence we have that too
the cola super deep borehole was just
nine inches in diameter and at forty
thousand two hundred thirty feet it's
the deepest hole on Earth it took almost
20 years to reach its depth of seven and
a half miles that Mill's hole is deep in
the net well that's true but that's
another episode yeah they pulled some
crazy stuff out of Mel's hole
Cola super deep was abandoned in 1992
when the Drillers encountered higher
than expected temperatures over 350
degrees Fahrenheit the drill just
couldn't handle the heat seven and a
half miles is a deep hole but it's 4 000
miles to the Earth's core so the cola
super deep is nothing and since grade
school we've been taught that the Earth
is made up of the crust the mantle and
the core and the core is two layers the
outer core is almost 1400 miles thick
and mostly made of liquid iron and
nickel the inner core is a solid sphere
with a radius of about 750 miles and the
inner core is thought to be comprised
mostly of iron and some nickel but if
we've only dug seven and a half miles
down how do we know for sure what's down
there well we don't but by using
different methods scientists can take a
guess
the primary way we've learned about the
earth's core is through the study of
seismic waves these are waves of energy
that travel through the Earth's layers
they move at different speeds depending
on the density and the composition of
the layer they're passing through
further Evidence comes from the Earth's
magnetic field which is best explained
by a Dynamo effect this is the spinning
motion of the liquid iron and nickel
which generates the feel but something
strange happened at the beginning of
this year the Earth's inner core stops
spinning
now it's believed that the core started
spinning again but in a different
direction and nobody really knows what
caused this we can only guess a few
months later it was determined that the
Earth has an inner inner core of solid
iron about 400 miles wide so new
discoveries are always being made and
everything we know about the inner earth
is just educated guesses why couldn't
the Earth be Hollow or at least have
enormous hollowed-out spaces that could
support life
the Skeptics have argued that you can't
have life inside the Earth the main
reason there's no water well when the
cola super deep borehole was being
drilled fossilized Plankton were found
miles below the surface still those are
fossils maybe millions of years old what
about now well in 2014 scientists
discovered water hundreds of miles below
the Earth's surface not just a little
water they found so much water you can
fill all the Earth's oceans with it
three times
most of the Earth's water is not on the
surface it's inside this water exists
between 250 and 410 miles under the
surface in an area called a transition
zone a buffer layer that separates the
upper from the lower mantle now if
there's water down there I wonder what
else could be down there well in 2019
geologists from Princeton University
published a study that surprised
everyone they use supercomputers to
analyze seismic data from some of the
largest earthquakes ever recorded
including the 8.2 magnitude Quake that
hit Bolivia in 1994. earthquakes that
big reverberate through the entire
planet we may not feel them but
seismographs can detect them analysis
showed that beneath the surface of the
Earth are vast planes and mountains
taller than the Himalayas all deep
within the Earth how deep 410 miles the
same depth as where the water is found
the transition zone
so what about the entrances at the poles
well pictures are hard to find and
they're allegedly all altered by NASA
which we know they do but there are a
few photos and videos out there of the
polls that show something strange
these photos were taken by the ss7
satellite in 1968 in one photograph the
North Pole was covered by clouds and
another photograph the same area had no
clouds revealing a massive hole where
the pole would be
this was taken from the ISS in March of
2015. NASA says that's a typhoon fair
enough
but in 1987 the Russian space station
Mir recorded something at the North Pole
that is definitely not a typhoon
what is this
[Music]
a hollow Earth theory has been around
for centuries at one point in history it
was the mainstream scientific view but
is there really evidence to support the
hollow Earth theory
well yes and no modern hollow Earth
theory always starts with Edmund Haley
he's a famous astronomer which gives the
theory some legitimacy Haley put forth
the idea because he couldn't explain why
magnetic poles were moving he figured
there were shells inside the earth that
moved independently of each other and he
was almost right during Haley's time it
wasn't yet known that the Earth's core
spins which creates the magnetic field
but he was correct that sections of the
inner earth can move independently of
each other including the core as we only
recently discovered mathematician
Leonard Euler gets credit for pushing
the hollow or theory in the 18th century
now I'm not sure how he became attached
to the theory there's no evidence he
ever said anything about it the concept
of agartha as a legendary Subterranean
world was first mentioned in the late
19th century French occultist and
esoteric writer Alexander santeve
introduced the idea in a book he
published in 1885 and according to his
writing agartha was a place of ancient
wisdom and spiritual enlightenment but
he never found actual hard evidence that
it was a real place he actually never
looked the idea caught on with other
occultists and theosophists like Madame
blavatsky but the only evidence they
provide of the hollow Earth comes from
visions and telepathic communication and
I'll leave it to you to determine if
that's proof enough most modern Hollow
Earth myths come from the Jules Verne
novel Journey to the Center of the Earth
when this story was published in 1864 it
was a phenomenon and made Jules Verne
one of the most famous authors in the
world be before there were Blockbuster
films there was Jules Verne now Admiral
Bird's diary describes how he flew into
the hollow Earth and had a meeting with
an advanced race of beings who warned
him about war and nuclear weapons and
this is a common theme in science
fiction in the 1950s and 1960s Admiral
Bird's story is basically the same plot
as The Day the Earth Stood Still it just
takes place in agartha I covered Admiral
Bird's diary in the other episode I also
explained whether the diary is real or
not spoiler alert it's not
now the water found inside the earth is
real and when the discovery was made we
were click baited into thinking there
are these vast oceans inside the earth
and there may be but that's not what
this discovery showed there is a massive
amount of water in the Earth's mantle
but it's trapped inside rocks and
minerals
yep lots of it it's a process called
mineral hydration it's a good way to
lock water in in a dry environment for
example the surface of the Moon is
covered in water the water is just
embedded in the lunar soil so the water
inside the earth is real just not in a
way that's obvious and the mountains
inside the Earth are also real but also
not how we might think again we were
click bait into thinking they're a huge
Open Spaces underground with mountain
ranges and you can't help but picture
scenes from Godzilla versus Kong
foreign
but that's not what they found there are
mountains of material that are denser
than the material around them it's still
solid-ish material just of different
densities the NASA video is a typhoon
and the video taken for Mir was a hoax
but you probably knew that now it's true
there aren't a lot of satellite pictures
of the poles and there is a lot of
speculation about this the truth is
there aren't a lot of satellites there
it's not worth taking a lot of
photographs of the poles because not
much changes and photos that are almost
Pure White are hard to analyze now there
are a couple of satellites in polar
orbit that measure how much the ice caps
are melting they're not well
a few years ago you can maybe make that
argument but NASA reports that
Antarctica is losing around 150 billion
tons of ice per year yeah but when does
NASA ever tell the truth of that now
that's a fair point but just last week
it was reported that Antarctica is
experiencing a Six Sigma event which
happens every seven and a half million
years oh this sounds bad well it ain't
good but assuming we're not all
underwater I'll get into that in a
future episode as for things I can
explain there are witness reports of
UFOs flying into Mount Shasta no video
that I can find but multiple Witnesses
have seen this and I think they're
probably telling the truth UFOs are
coming out of the ocean we've all seen
video of that and if the aliens landed
tomorrow and held a press conference
where they said we're not from another
planet but we're from inside this planet
well that would make sense to me
scientifically speaking that's more
plausible than creating wormholes and
bending space time to travel through
space but until the aliens announce
themselves or until our government
starts telling the truth we're just not
going to know for sure and there are
many many interesting stories about the
hollow Earth and there's no way to cover
them in one episode so keep an eye out
for more on this topic now it's true we
can't prove the Earth is hollow it's
also true we can't prove it's not if you
follow this channel you know I try to
find as much truth in these Mysteries as
I can
but the real truth is some Mysteries
just can't be solved and those are my
favorite
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ there's Heckle
fish sleep
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do him a favor like
subscribe comment share it's annoying to
hear us say it over and over but it
really does help the channel like every
topic we cover on the white files this
one was recommended by you so if there's
a story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the wifiles.com tips if
you'd like to join a great Community
Check out the white files Discord
there's thousands of people on there
they're all into the same stuff that we
are and it's free to join now special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible you guys are amazing
and we could not do this without you if
you'd like to support the channel become
a member on patreon for as little as
three bucks a month you get all kinds of
perks like early access to videos with
no commercials special access on Discord
and all kinds of stuff now if that's not
for you maybe grab something from the
Wi-Fi store
[Music]
talking fishes
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]